[موسيقى]
على ضفاف الفرات وتخوم باديه الشام تحمل
المسؤوليه كان طفلا تحدى اقرانه في تسلق
النخيل راسما مع لعبته المفضله مسيره حياه
تجاوز فيها الصعاب الكبرى في بلد نهشته
الحروب واضاف الحصار من كل صوب انا اعتقد
ان النشاه الاولى يعني لعبت دورا كبيرا في
ما وصل اليه يعني يمكن ان اطلق عليه انه
عراقي صميم جدا كان الرجل وفيا لعراقه
وفيا لناسه وفيا للكثير من تفاصيل هذا
البلد الذي يعني عشقه يعني يعني عشقا
كبيرا
[موسيقى]
غرب الانبار في حديثه حيث تتصافح الصحراء
والريفولي يتجمع النقيض الى النقيض نشا
ضيفي في جو اسري متشبعا بثقافه والفكر
والعمل الحزبي كما قلق عالي جدا هيبه مع
خلق وهذا يعني شخص
يتميز به القاده ويكون له شخصيه اعتباريه
وفي نفس الوقت تعامل مع الناس بحب وبادب
وبخلق
يتحلى بصفاته الفارس العربي الاصيل تعلمت
من عنده الاراده القويه
الصبر كيفيه مواجهه صعوبات الحياه
[موسيقى]
في مسار شديد التعقيد طلب منه ان يواجه
طبول الحرب مستندا في ذلك على مهارات
التفاوض والحوار الا ان الرياح لم تاتي
بما تشتهي سفنه
[موسيقى]
هو لاعب بارع في جوله اريد لها ان تكون
خاسره
[موسيقى]
مهاراتك الدبلوماسيه معروفه للجميع لكن
اليوم فاجاتنا بمهاراتك الرياضيه دكتور
منذ وجود في بغداد كانت حقيبه التنس معي
واخرج فتره الظهر العب تنس اروح الى نادي
القوه الجويه اللي هو احسن نادي رياضي في
بغداد
العبد مع اصدقائي
وشركائي في اللعب قبل التنس طبعا من كان
عمري اربع سنوات تعلمت السباحه
وهذا شيء ضروري جدا في حديثنا لان احنا
يعني مدينه على نهر الفرات فيجب ان نتعلم
السباحه من سن مبكره جدا كي لا نغرق هذه
اول مره اراك فيها تمسك مضرب التنس وليس
السبحه ما سر هذه السبحه التي ترافقك انا
اتسلى بها واعتادت عليها في كل الظروف
السبحه معي ما عدا الاجتماعات الرسميه في
داخل الدوله ما استخدمها ولكن في كل
المفاوضات الامم المتحده في طهران
مع الاطراف الاخرى انا كنت اسبح
[موسيقى]
لاجي صبري الحديثي الحديث نسبه لحديثه
لماذا تذكر عن النشاه في تلك المدينه وكيف
تاثرت بمحيطها ولادتي ونشاتي كانت في هذه
المنطقه الغنيه بالتنوع الجغرافي والثقافي
مجموعه كبيره من القرى يصل عددها الى
احوال 130 قريه تشكلت منها مدينه حديثه
احنا بيتنا كان في قلب المدينه ساقي اللي
تجيب المي من من النواعير حتى توزع على
الارض الزراعيه في القريه كانت تمر من
قدام باب بيتنا بحوالي مترين هذه الحياه
الهادئه البساطه لاعتماد على الطبيعه في
توفير وسائل العيش وادوات المنزل وكل سبل
الحياه
انتقلت كلها هذه الى المدينه للتنوع
الجغرافي في حديثه هناك نهر
وريف ومدينه
وباديه فلدينا اربعه عناصر اضيف لها عنصر
خامس هو شركه نفط العراق اقامت محطه كي 3
وفيها مدينه سكنيه للعاملين اهلا انتقلنا
بحكم عمل المرحوم والدي في شركه نفط
العراق انتقلنا للسكن فيها في عام 60
الخدمات متطوره جدا
المرافق متطوره جدا نادي متقدم ساحات
للتنس ساحات لكره القدم للسله ساحه جولف
السكان المدينه هذه
من انتماعات
قوميه ودينيه مختلفه كلهم تجمعهم المواطنه
العراقيه هذا عامل مضاف للتنوع الموجود في
مدينه حديثه حدثني اكثر عن الوالده
والاسره انا واحد من تسعه اخوه واخوات لكن
انا كنت الاصغر بين الذكور وموجود دائما
في البيت فكانت المرحومه والدته تعتمد
عليه كثيرا وتشركني في كل شؤون البيت هي
تديرها على ان الوالده المرحوم كان يعمل
لفتره طويله نمت فيا من وقت مبكر روح
المسؤوليه والثقب النفس والتصرف والاراده
الشخصي تعلمت اللغه الانجليزيه قبل رفاقك
معك بنفس المرحله العمريه هل كان السبب
احتكاكك المباشر ببعض من يعمل بمحطه
الذين يتحدثون اللغه الانجليزيه جلست مع
شقيقي الاكبر اكبر مني وابن خالي كان
يدرسهم شقيقي الاكبر المرحوم شكري كنت
مستمع معهم انا كنت يعني بالرابع
الابتدائي هم متقدمين عليه فانا استمع
لتدريس حاول اشاركهم عندما وصلت للصف
الخامس انا كنت اتصور نفسي انا انا اعرف
اللغه الانجليزيه فلم اتهيب من دراسه
اللغه عندما انتقلنا الى كيثري كنت اروح
لنادي الموظفين فكانت مكتبه في نادي
موظفين تصفح الكتب
فوجدت كتاب ممتاز كتاب كبير
لقواعد اللغه الانجليزيه وبدات احاول
اتعلم منه اقرا منه بشكل ولذلك في هذا كان
طبعا يعزز معرفتي باللغه الانجليزيه كثيرا
بعد تخرجي من الثانويه وجدت نفسي في قسم
اللغه الانجليزيه في كليه الاداب لكن لم
تحقق النجاح المطلوب او المتوقع منك في
الثانويه مصمت بوعك مرضيه حاده في اثناء
الامتحانات قبل الامتحانات كم يوم هبط
معدل كثيرا في في عند التخرج فذهبت الى
الى دراسه وفضلا اللغه الانجليزيه كانت هي
افضل الدروس عندي كنت من المتفوقين في
التخرج وعدت عينت معيزا في في ذات القسم
ايضا من كليه الشرطه وكنت فرحان انك رفضت
بالكوريه فلماذا تقدمت لها من الاساس اخي
الاكبر
قال لي احنا كل يوم داخلين بمركز شرطه هم
كانوا من من قيادي حزب البعث فاريدك تدخل
كليه الشرطه حتى تعاوننا في المستقبل
فاجبرت على دخول كليه الشرطه ولا مقنع
فيها لكن انا كنت صبي صغير ما كنت اقدر
اعارض رحت الكره الشرطه رفضت لاسباب تتعلق
باخواني
لم تتحطم احلام الحديث على صخره المرض نهض
من كبوته ليواصل مساره في تعويض خسارته
وتحويلها الى نجاح انتقل معه من الجامعه
الى ميدان المهنه والعمل في صفوف الدوله
العراقيه اختر دراسه اللغه الانجليزيه
تفوقت في البكالوريوس في جامعه بغداد ايضا
لكن المفارقه انك لم تكمل مشوارك في
التعليم العالي الا بعد فتره هل كان ذلك
بسبب انضمامك لجريده الثوره وكانها تاثير
على
تخطيطك في الدراسه انا بدات العمل في
الجريده في اربعه ثمانيه عام 68 عندي انا
زمان الدكتوراه من عام 71
ولم التحق بها فكان مساله تحدي ان اثبت
وجودي في الجريده لو كان يعني علاقتي مع
رئيس التحرير العلاقه الوديه المشاركه في
تاسيس هذا المشروع يعني جعلتني استمر في
الجريده اواصل العمل في الجريده الى
العلاقه وديه لكن انت كنت دائما تمشي عكس
التيار دكتور في الجريده وكان هناك بعض
الصدمات مع رئيس التحرير حينها طارق عزيز
انا لم افهم طبيعه هذه العلاقه هل فعلا
كانت علاقه اوديه في ظاهرها لكن في باطنها
تحمل شيء مختلف احنا في الحقيقه كنا
اصدقاء وكنا زملاء في الشهر الخامس من عام
69 عين رئيس تحرير لجريه الثوره وانا كنت
رئيس قسم الترجمه اضاف لي قسم اخر وبعد
فتره انتقلت من هذا القسم الى وظيفه معاون
مدير التحرير يعني مطبخ صناعه الجريده
فمضينا في هذا العمل ارسلنا قواعد العمل
في الجريده وكان في الحقيقه يعني الخلاف
او الاختلاف في وجهه النظر بيننا يدور حول
النهج الذي يجب ان تسير عليه الجريده انا
كنت اميل
واعمل من اجل ان نحن نعزز الطابع المهني
الحقيقي للجريف جريده ليست منشورا حزبيا
هو كان يميل الى الجانب الاخر هو كاتب من
من ابرز كتاب ومثقفي حزب البعث فنحن شركاء
في اداره هذا المشروع عندما نختلف في
الرؤيه يفضل طبعا انه واحد من انه يخرج
فانا فضلت ان اخرج من الجريده وبقينا على
العلاقه الوديه هل تذكر اول لقاء جمعه كم
صدام حسين صارت صيغه بعد اثنين اثنين انه
الكادر الثاني والثالث في مؤسسه الاعلام
يحضر اجتماع مكتب الاعلام اللي كان يديره
هو السيد النائب صدام حسين رحمه الله كان
نائبا عن ذلك فكنت انا احضر معهم ويشوفني
وتتعرف علي او اول مره اتكلم معه بشكل
مباشر في عام 74 في اجتماع رسمي وابديت
اعتراض على تصرف اعلامي عمله مديريه الامن
العامه مع اداره التلفزيون واللي هي جزء
من وزاره الاعلام فانا اعترضت على
الفريقين فسال هو الموجودين هل منكم من
يؤيد فلان او من يعارضه لم يتحدث احد
المرحوم طارق عزيز تحدث قال انا اؤيد فلان
فهو مباشره قال انا اؤيد فلان فهو يعرف
موقفي ويعرف تصرفي ويعرفني شخصيا من هذا
من وقت مبكر يعني كان الرجل مستمعا بعكس
الصوره النمطيه التي نشرت عنها او يقال
عنه بانه كان صارم كان هو الاكثر قدره على
الاستماع الاكثر انفتاحا على ما يطرحها
الطرف الاخر اللي يتحدث فيه اجتماع من
مجلس الوزراء كان لا قرارا الا بعد ان
يسال الجميع ويستمع تماما لوجهات النظر
التي تطرح ولا يقاطع احد ولا يقمع احد
يقمع رايه واذكر مره كنت اتحدث وحاول احد
المسؤولين ان يقاطعني فمنعه قال له احنا
نستمع لوزير الخارجيه المفروض يتكلم هو
يتحدث عندي عن امثله كثيره انا اعترض فيها
على اشياء قرارات تاخذها النوابه او هو
وهو مصادق عليها ويستجيب لرايه
عندما نائبا اتخذ قرار بابتعاثك الى لندن
وزف
ما خلفيات هذا القرار انا بعد الاختلاف في
وجهات النظر والرؤى في الجريده مع رئيس
التحرير ذهبت عليه في اواخر عام 74 وكان
اصبح وزير الثقافه فقلت له لم اعد استطيع
البقاء في الجريده نهائيا ويجب ان اخرج في
عام 74 قررت الامر ولكن بقرار نهائي قال
لي وين تروح قلت انتقل الى وزاره الخارجيه
وعندي انا زمان على الدكتوراه في بريطانيا
وعندي زماله كاندي داتا اللي هي تعادل
الدكتوراه في روسيا واكمل دراسي وهذا هدفي
كانوا طموحي فقال لي اقر لسيد النائب بان
تذهب مستشار صحفي في لندن وتؤسس مؤسسه
اعلاميه عراقيه في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
ابتعد ناجي عن المشهد العراقي بعد ان وصل
الى طريق مسدود اذ لم يعد قادرا على
السباحه عكس التيار عامل مستشارا صحفيا
لدى السفاره العراقيه في لندن مرحله تعد
الاكثر حساسيه في مشواره وعلاقته مع صدام
حسين فسرعان ما تحولت محطه الاستياء الى
محطه انجازات عكس ناجي من خلالها صوره
مغايره عن العراق اهلته لكسب الثقه الرجل
الاكثر صرامه صدام حسين من اهم القرارات
التي اتخذتها انشاء مركز ثقافي عراقي في
لندن السؤال ما الحاجه له في ظل وجود مكتب
في السفاره العراق غني جدا
بالادوات الثقافيه بالكنوز الثقافيه
والفنيه كان ينبغي استثمار هذا الثروه
الثقافيه والفنيه الهائله في العراق
للتعريف بالعراق والتعريف بح العراق
والازدهار الثقافي في شعرت بالحاجه الى
مؤسسه اعلاميه يعني تعمل بالوسائل
الثقافيه
وتخاطب الجمهور فكان المركز يا امه الاف
الناس لماذا صدر قرار بنقلك من لندن الى
بغداد هل كان الامر مرتبطا باحداث عام
1979 صارت هذه الحادثه التي سميت
بالمؤامره ولم تكن لا مؤامره ولا محاوله
انقلاب ولا شيء اعتقل فيها اشقاء الكبار
شكري ومحمد رحمه الله فعلى اثرها انا فصلت
من الحزب وصدر قرار بنقل الى بغداد ثم حصل
مؤتمر بالمستشارين الصحفيين في في شهر
التاسع يعني بعد حوالي شهرين من الاحداث
هذه احداث 79 عدت الى بغداد واجتمعنا
بمكتب الاعلام وكان رئيسه الرئيس صدام
فجلسنا معهم احد المستشارين سال الرئيس
قالوا احنا مستشارين صحفيين جايين من
الخارج نتمنى من سيادتك ان تعطينا توجيه
قالوا ليش تسالني انظروا لناجي الحديثي هو
النموذج الذي يجب ان تحتذوا به فهكذا كان
موقف مني رغم انه صدر قرار بالفصل
وبالنقل وهل تلقيت الى بغداد ولم تخشى ان
تلقى ذات المصير وما حصل مع محمد وشكري
اخواني انا انا لست موظف في الحزب انا
موظف في الدوري العراقي
فصدروا قرار بفصلي هذا لا يعني شيء
بالنسبه لي انه اغيب عن الدوله واغيب عن
وظيفتي انا الذي كنت اصر على العوده وعدت
بدون موافقه الوزاره وبقيت حوالي كم يوم
صدر قرار بتعيين مدير عام في وزاره
الثقافه والاعلام وتاسيس
دار الماموني الترجمه
انا في نهج النهج الذي يعني صرت عليه في
عملي في الصحافه في الداخل ثم في لندن
والنهج المهني النهج الجاد الحقيقي
المسؤول هذا النهج هو الذي يعني جعلني
اكسب ثقه الدوله واكسب ثقه الاخرين بغض
النظر عما حدث لعائلتي انا ذاك
[موسيقى]
بعد تعيينك مديرا للاعلام الخارجي وجدت
نفسك في اتون حرب عام
1991 ماذا كان دور دكتور ناجي صبري
الحديثي في تلك الحرب في عام 90
ابلغني الوزير بانه لا يرغب في تعيين مدير
عام الاعلام الخارجي نهائيا الوزير كان
المرحوم لطيف جاسم انا ذاهب والسبب طبعا
هو الاختلاف البين يعني والكبير بيني
وبينه في رؤيتنا الاعلام الخارجي في يوم
عشره ثمانيه جاء ابلغني انه انت تكون مدير
عام للاعلام الخارجي فانا ما اريد اصير
قال لي هذا القرار من فوق عرفت انه هو
طبعا كان جاي من خارج الوزاره وصاح انه
صدر امر تعيين ناجي الحديث
عندما وقعت الحرب في 17 كانون الثاني
يناير من عام 91 كان لدينا يعني عدد كبير
من الصحفيين الرئيس بوش كان من هناك يضغط
على رؤساء المؤسسات الاعلاميه الكبرى في
امريكا لاخراج مراسليهم من العراق
سفير امريكا جولسن كان في بغداد اجتمع
بالصحفيين الامريكيين
وابلغهم بانه احنا سنملا ارض العراق حفر
فاخرجوا
خرج اكثر من 1400 صحفي لكن بقوا عدد من
الصحفيين وانا كنت اشجعهم على البقاء
وزيري كان ايضا يريد يضغط عليها لاخراج
الصحفيين هو كان يخشى ان هؤلاء الصحفيين
راح يسكنون جواسيس
واحنا نراقبهم وان لا ينقلون هم موجودين
في في الفندق واحنا نعطيهم تقارينا وحتى
نافذه النا حتى نوصل ما يحدث الى العالم
وظليت متمسك بهذا الاجراء الى الايام
الاخيره في الحرب وانا اخفي بعض الصحفيين
واحاول ان اسوف بقرار الوزير على صحفي
واحد هو صحفي اردني الوزير قال لي اخرج
الصحفيين الاجانب فانا ابقيت ميشيل الحاج
في في بغداد كان مدير وكاله
ولما سالني بعدين قلت له هو مو صح هو صحفي
عربي
وساهم هذا الرجل
بايصال كثير من الرسائل والوقائع التي
تجري في العراق الى الخارج الى ان انتهت
الحرب
ورجع الوزير اضغط ايضا لاخراجهم وحدث
انذاك ان احد المسؤولين العراقيين كان في
الاردن
والتقى بالمرحوم جلاله الملك حسين
فالملك قال يعني ليش يطلعون الصحفيين
المرحوم الملك حسين ارسل رساله الى الرئيس
صدام عبر هذا المسؤول انه هذا العمل ليس
في صالح العراق فلذلك جاء الوزير عليه قال
لي طلعوا الصحفيين قلت ايه طلعوا ظل واحد
او اثنين قال
خليهم يقول فانا اخذت هذه اشاره قلت خلي
يرجعون صعبين ورجعت الصحفيين للاخرين كلهم
الى الى الداخل هل فعلا كانت تلك الحرب
القاتره التي قادت مقطوره ازمات للعراق
اوصلته الى ما هو عليه اليوم هو مشروع
الذي بدا تنفيذه في شهر الثامن
هو مشروع كبير مشروع اسرائيلي تدمير
العراق فكانوا يستثمروا كل خطا ترتكب
القياده العراقيه
لفرض مزيد من العراقيل والعقوبات والاشياء
الباهظه على العراق فعدم انسحاب العراق من
الكويت جعلهم يعني
يصدرون بعبر مجلس الامن قرارات
ليس لها يعني سابق في في تاريخ الامم
المتحده يعني خلاص 687
قرار خطير جدا يعني استعمار العراق الامم
المتحده التي جاءت لنصره الشعوب والحفاظ
على سيادتها واستقلالها وحل النزاعات في
الضرر السلميه
هي تشرعا
استيلاء دوله على دوله اخرى وفقدان سياده
دوله
مصيبه كانت
[موسيقى]
بكل منصب وزير الخارجيه
بالنسبه صبر مكافاه كما راها البعض فعل
الجانب الاخر قتل اخر رمز للدبلوماسيه
العراقيه بكل ما اوتي من قوه محاولا انقاذ
بلاد ما بين النهرين من طريق لا تعرف
نهايته في وقت قرعت فيه طبول الحرب
بالعوده الى مساره المهني دكتور جاء
تعيينك سفير
العراق في النمسا هذا التعيين استغربت منه
حقيقه لانه القرار صدر عام
1979 لكنه نفذ عام
1998 لماذا كل هذا التاخير
انا ما عندما عدت للعراق لحضور المؤتمر
المستشارين الصحفي الرئيس صدام حضر معنا
اجتماع في وزاره النفط اثناء اللقاء كتب
ورقه واعطاها المرافقه كان احد الزملاء
المستشارين جالس قريبا فعندما خرجنا قال
لي اسمك اول اسم في ورقه ومعه ثلاثه اسماء
اخرى فرحت الوزاره الاعلام حتى اودع
الوزير الرجعه قلت لها استاذ اريد ارجع
انا من لندن الى بغداد
قال لي روح راح تسمع خبر يفرحك سافرت الى
لندن بعد حوالي اسبوعين صدر قرار بتعيين
لثلاث اسماء الاخرى سفراء وانا اسمي مش
موجود عرفت طبعا بعدين ان الرئيس رشحني
سفير في عام 79 ويبدو انه فاعل خير
يبدو ان فاعل خير
طرح انه لماذا سفير يتعين مدير عام فلذلك
المدير عام في وزاره الثقافه وبعدها جرت
انا سمعت انه اتخذ قرار في عام 82 لتعيين
سفير في انجلترا وايضا حدث تدخل اخر ولم
اعين وحدث وعام 86 كان رايي اعين سفير في
سفير العراق في اليونسكو ايضا حدث اعتراف
وبقيت في الوزراء في عام 98 صدر قرار
بتعيين سفير الى النمسا
لتصبح لاحقا يعني وزيرا للخارجيه وتحمل
الحقيبه الاهم يعني النمسا
تجمع جانبي العمل الدبلوماسي الثنائي
ومتعدد الاطراف يعني اكون ممثل العراق في
الوكاله الدولي للطاقه الذريه ممثل العراق
الدائم في مكتب الامم المتحده
وممثل العراق الدائم في منظمه المتحده
للتنميه الصناعيه وغيرها من المنظمات
الدوليه وفوق هذا كنت ايضا سفير العراق
غير المقيم في جمهوريه سلوفاكيا انا بغيت
فتره قليله طبعا في النمسا وعينت وزير
دوله الشؤون الخارجيه
[موسيقى]
توليت الخارجيه مع ارث معقد يعني الكثير
من الازمات كيف تعاملت مع هذه المعادله
عندما عينت وزير دوله للشؤون الخارجيه لم
احمل مسؤوليات انذاك يعني مسؤولياتي كانت
بسيطه بصفه وزير دوله لكن اصبحت في قلب
الوزاره بنيت خطه
للمرحله التاليه في عملي طيب كيف تضع
خطه مستقبليه وانت لست في المنصب يعني هل
كان عندك احساس انك انت التالي او بناء
على ماذا
الاحساس العام انه هي هذه مرحله
ولكن اكدها الرئيس المرحوم صدام حسين قال
لي انت تبقى سنه وزير دوله
وبعدها تصير وزير خارجيه فدات اضع الخطه
اللازمه التي ساتبعها عندما
اتسلم مسؤوليه وزاره الخارجيه الحقيقه هو
لم ينتظر سنه اقل من اربعه اشهر انا عينت
وزير خارجي وزاره الخارجيه او السياسه
الخارجيه عموما في العراق كانت تعاني من
من ازمات شديده يعني ازمه العلاقه مع
الامم المتحده كانت العلاقات متوتره مع
كثير من الدول العربيه
علاقه متوتره مع ايران خلفيات الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه
وكان موضوع يعني عادت هيكله وزاره
الخارجيه وتطويرها
متاحه لك بحريه القرار ام انك كنت وزير
خارجيه تنفيذي تاتيك القرارات من بغداد من
القياده وتنفذها في كل الوظائف اللي كنت
تسلمها كنت احاول املا الوظيفه بشكل كامل
كل صلاحيات يستخدمها
واتصرف في الوظيفه كما هو مطلوب مهنيا في
هذه الوظيفه فانا اعرف ان وزير الخارجيه
يجب ان يرتبط برئيس الجمهوريه رئيس
الجمهوريه هو المسؤول عن عن السياسه
الخارجيه وليس اي شخص اخر في الدوله
فلذلك رفضت عن ان يكون بيني وبين الرئيس
صدام حسين اي وسيط والرئيس كان برحب بهذا
كان وزير الخارجيه عندما يسافر هو سفرات
كثيره فياتي احد نواب رئيس الجمهوريه يكون
وزير خارجيه بالوكاله
فعندما جئت انا وزير خارجيه
الغى الرئيس صدام حسين هذا الاجراء هذا
التقليد المتبع
ففي البدايه
عين ابنه المرحوم قصي
انه عندما يسافر وزير الخارجيه قصي صدام
حسين هو وزير الخارجيه وكالته بعد سته
اشهر خبرني سكرتير رئيس قال قصي عنده
اشغال كثيره ما يقدر يجيب مكانك على طول
انت اختار الوزير المناسب اللي تريده يكون
مكانك عندما تسافر فانا اخترت زميلي
وصديقي الدكتور همام عبد الخالق وزير
التعليم العالي والبحث العلمي ان هو يكون
وكيل الدائم
من التحديات واعاده هيكله وزاره الخارجيه
لكن ما هو اصعب ملف كان بين يديك وانت
وزير للخارجيه وكان اصعب ملف
ادق ملف هو ملف العلاقه مع الامم المتحده
كانت العلاقه شائكه جدا مجلس الامن اتخذ
قرارات وكان ردود الحكومه العراقيه بعض
الاحيان يعني تتسم بالانفعال انا عندما
اتيت الى الوزاره بدات اتصرف على اساس
النهج الواقعي للتعامل مع الامم المتحده
لمحاوله جهد الامكان ابعاد التاثير
الاماكن البريطاني عن مجلس الامن الذي كان
يسخر طبعا مجلس الامن كمطرقه للطرق على
راس العراق امنا موقف ثابت لثلاث دول من
الدول الكبرى في مجلس الامن معارض لشن
الحرب على العراق بالشكل الذي كانت تريده
بريطانيا وامريكا بالحديث عن المتحده
القيد كلمه للرئيس صدام حسين في سبتمبر
عام 2002 هل فعلا صدام حسين هو من كتب هذه
الكلمه في صباح اليوم باللي كان مقرا القي
الكلمه وصلت على بريد الممثلين الدائمه
العراق في الامم المتحده رساله من وزاره
الخارجيه تقول هذه رساله الرئيس صدام حسين
المجتمع الدولي تقرر ان يلقيها وزير
الخارجيه في كلمته في الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده كلمه كانت كبيره وكان
النهج المكتوبه فيه كان يخاطب جمهور عراقي
وعربي ولذلك حذفت انا من الكلمه اكثر من
نص الكلمه
وكتبت برقيه الى بغداد ان كلمه طويله
والوقت المخصص لكل ممثل دوله 20 دقيقه حا
ولت انا اشيل كل التفاصيل غير المطلوبه
والتي فيها يعني فيها مخاطبه عاطفيه
لجمهور عراقي وعربي
وليس معنيا بها الجمهور الاجنبي والمجتمع
الدولي هؤلاء سفراء ورؤساء الدول والرؤساء
حكومات من وجهه نظرك انك ضبطت الايقاع لكن
وجهه نظر العالم
الغاربه كنت متهم وتم شن هجوم كبيره عليك
حتى انه احدى الصحف وصفتك اسمح لي بالكذاب
مجتمع مع مع خبراء قانونيين امريكيين
وبريطانيين في مقر البعث الامريكيه صيغون
قرار بشن الحرب على العراق بغطاء الامم
المتحده
فكتبت برقيه من هناك الى الرئيس
اقترحت به اقترحت في البرقيه اعاده
الموافقه على المفتشين بدون قيد او شرط
بسرعه وقلت له
الامريكان يعدون لمشروع قرار يجيز شن
الحرب على العراق
بغطاء الشرعيه الدوليه فبعد ساعتين اتصل
بها سكرتير الرئيس قال حصلت الموافقه فانا
قعدت المفتشين يوم 16 هاجمني الناطق باسم
البيت الابيض واتهمني بالكذب والمراوغه
ويوم 19 عندما القيت الكلمه هاجمت جريده
نيويورك بوست وشوهت
صورتي ونشرتها على الصفحه الاولى
ومع مانشيت عريض
بالكذب نعم لاير يعني الكذاب الكذاب هل
كذب ناجي صبري من اجل تلميع صوره النظام
انا قلت الحقيقه احنا ما عندنا اسلحه
اذا انتم عندكم اي هاجس ان عندنا اسلحه
دمار شامل تعالوا احنا نوديكم على اي مكان
تريدوا
[موسيقى]
جاء في مذكرات البرادعي بانه قال لك
ساعدنا نساعدك ما صحه هذا الكلام لا قال
لهذا الكلام ولا انا قلت له اي شيء ولا
انا شفته خارج وزاره الخارجيه اطلاقا هو
يقول في الكتاب انه دعاني ناجي صبري لحفل
العشاء انا لا دعيت الحفل عشاء وكيف ادعو
يعني ادعوهم شو المناسبه يعني هو ضيف علي
ضيف على العراق هو جزء من المشروع
الامريكي سادته هم الذين خططوا الحرب
وشنوا الحرب ما كان يحتاجون واحد يحرضهم
العرب في هذه المرحله
وعراقهم العربي الاصيل يواجه هذا العدوان
بهذه الشجاعه وهذا الصمود البطولي
من العرب ان يدافعوا عن انفسهم وان يقفوا
وقفه حقيقيه توقعت
الكثير ومن الرؤ
ساء الحقيقي بعكس ما هو واضح ومعلن امام
الشعوب نحن دائما في العراق ما نظن الا
الخير
باخواننا العرب ومن الطبيعي ان نتوقع
الخير من اخواننا العرب لانه العراق لم
يقصر مع عربي انا في اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه
العرب في القاهره في
تشرين ثانيه نوفمبر من عام 2002 وكان تلوح
في الافق محاوله لطرح
مطلب على جامعه الدول العربيه
بتنحي الرئيس صدام حسين عن رئاسه اجاره
محاوله في الاجتماع
ووعدت انتهى الموضوع فانا تحدثت
قلت يا اخوان هل طلبت دوله منكم هل طلبت
من العراق شيء طلع طلبه سلاح ولم يقدم
العراق سلاحه لها هل طلب الدوله منكم مال
ولم يكن المال العراق امامها هل طلب
الدوله او احتاجت رجال ولم يكن رجال
العراق مستعدين امامها
كل هذا احنا كنا نعمله ولا ليس بمنيه على
اي واحد انما هذا واجب العراق وهذا هو دور
العراق وهاي مكانه العراق كل ما نتمنى
منكم يا اخوان ان لا ياتينا شر واذى منكم
ونشكركم
في قمه ان رامز فيلد قال بان بما معناه
بانه العراق انتهى يعني صدام حوصر
وناجي لاحد
رجالات صدام حسين لن يستطيع العوده وكان
يقصدك انت لم يستطيع العوده الى العراق
ومع ذلك عدت
بناء على ماذا قال احنا اطبقنا على صدام
ولديه ومساعديه فصحفي قال رامز كيف اطبقتم
عليهم احد مساعدي صدام وزير الخارجيه
موجود في القاهره خرجوا الان في القاهره
فالرمس فيلد قال
لنرى كيف سيعود العراق فاتخذت احتياطاتي
فكنت ابلغ الصحفيين اليتوني اللي يسالوني
متى ستعود اقول لهم عندي جوله في البلاد
العربيه
فخبرت صديقي وزميلي محمود حمود وزير
خارجيه لبنان خبرته بالموضوع قلت له اني
راح اقول انا راح اجي ازور لبنان
وجماعتك في وزاره الخارجيه راح يسالوك
يقولوا لك وزير الخارجيه العراقي راح يجي
الى لبنان
التواصل مع القياده العراقيه وانقطع تماما
[موسيقى]
حكايتي اسلحه الدمار الشامل في العراق
باحتلال بغداد لم يعد ممكنا للحديث ان
يحاور الدبابه بالكلمه لكن الكلمه تحيي
الذاكره والاحزان وقد تشعل الحنين والشوقه
لوطن عاش فيه اينما حل وارتحل
[موسيقى]
متى قررت مغادره العراق كان معنا قريب
سكرتير
وهو يعمل في يعني احدى الجهات العسكريه
الامنيه في يوم ثمانيه اخبرني بانه انتهى
كل شيء واقتربت القوات الامريكيه ودخلت
الى مركز بغداد
يوم تسعه يعني اللي هو اليوم الاسود
لاحتلال العراق
خرجت من بغداد في الساعه عشره وثلث صباحا
وصلت يعني حوالي بعد ثمان ساعات يلا وصلت
الى مدينه الفلوجه بغداد هي المسافه ما
تطول اربعين دقيقه وفي صباح اليوم
العاشر خرجنا من الفلوجه باتجاه حديثه
بعدين وصلنا الطريق باتجاه مدينه القائم
الحدوديه او حصيبه
اثناء الخروج من العراق كنت بالسياره ويا
الوالد والوالده كنت اشوف على الصحراء على
يسار الطريق
احنا متجهين الى الحدود العراقيه السوريه
واقول ويا نفسي هل راح اشوف العراق مره
ثانيه قبل الوصول الى حصيبه واذا واحد
ياتيني بين عراقي ففتحت النافذه السياره
حتى اتكلم معه وهو فتح الباب كله باب
السياره دخل نصف جسمه داخل السياره قال
وين رايحين حصيبه فغلق الباب ففتحنا
المجال دخلنا من داخل السيارات وتقدمنا
سيارتين الاخرى تاخرت وانتظرناهم ساعه
لكنه دهر كانت لانه يعني خفنا انه كشف
اولادي جاؤونا بعد ساعه تقريبا دخلنا الى
مدينه حصيبه فالمهرب خبانا في احد البيوت
المهجوره وظلينا الى ان الى حوالي سبعه
وسبعه ونص بالليل
فدخلنا ودعنا على الحد على الحدود السوريه
الحدود ما هي كانت يعني حاجز ترابي ارتفاع
مترين اكثر من مترين المهم يعني بالقوه
عبرنا من الساتر في شخص في دير الزور احنا
موصينا نروح على هذا الشخص هو يدبر لنا
سبيل الانتقال الى دمشق قلت لا اريدك تبلغ
الان
الحكومه السوريه بانه انا دخلت في الاراضي
السوريه فراح بلغ هو بعد تقريبا ساعه
تقريبا
جاءنا مسؤول للجهه هذه الامنيه
وارحب بنا باسم الحكومه السوريه وباسم
الرئاسه السوريه كيف كان وقع لحظات الخروج
الاخير من العراق كان يعني ينطبق علينا
قول الشاعر زهير بن ابي سلمى ثلاث
يعز الصبر عند حلولها
ويذهل عنها عقل كل لبيب خروج اضطرار من
بلاد تحبها
وفرقه خلانا وفقد حبيبه احنا هذه الرزايا
الثلاثه هذه المصائب الثلاثه حلت بينا في
في ذلك الوقت يعني يعني بدون ايضا اللهم
الا اذا كان ذنبي انه انا يعني احب بلدي
العراق مثل ما احب ابوي وامي حقيقه انا
كنت انظر من النافذه
يعني انظر
من اقتربنا من نهر الفرات العظيم
ومن اقتربنا من مدينتي حديثه
وايضا يعني طوال الطريقه الصحراوي يعني
انظر الى الاراضي هذه الجميله
ويعني تدور في افكارها يعني
يوفقنا الله وعن اللي العوده
يعني اهلي يعني
[موسيقى]
بعد ان خرجت من العراق توجهت الى سوريا من
سوريا الى الدوحه ما قصه المجيء الى
الدوحه كيف وصلت الدوحه خلال فتره اقامتنا
في سوريا والتي استمرت اقل من سبعه اشهر
جاءتنا دعوه كريمه من بلد كريم وقائد كريم
من سمو الامير الوالد والشيخ حمد بن خليفه
الفاني
اطال الله في عمره ورعاه بالخير والعافيه
وصلنا الى الدوحه في بدايه شهر تشرين
الثاني نوفمبر عام 2003 دكتور كنت في
زيارات دائمه عندما كنت في المنصب للدوحه
الان انت مستقر في الدوحه كما قلت لاكثر
من 20 عام كيف وجدت مسيره التطور والنهضه
والازدهار في قطر انا اول مره جئت الى قطر
كنت وكيل وزاره الثقافه والاعلام على راس
وفي الثقافي عراقي كبير لاقامه الاسبوع
الثقافي العراقي هنا في بدايه عام 94
ثم بعد انقطاع
حوالي سبع سنوات في عام 2001 جئت الى هنا
بعد ان توليت وزاره الخارجيه
وتكررت زياراتي وفي عام 2003 اقمت هنا
الحقيقه انني كل اسبوع ارى شيئا جديدا
يعني المس هنا
بعين المراقب من الداخل المس التقدم
الحثيث الذي يجري في كل الميادين بالحديث
ايضا عن الدوحه دكتور هناك قصيده لصدام
حسين نشرتها لقد صدام حسين على تويتر
واثارات الكثير من الجدل يمدح فيها
الدوحه وقطر انت تعرف خط صدام حسين جيدا
يعني هل هذا الخط هو خط صدام حسين فعلا
نعم هذا خط طهور رحمه الله نعم هذه قصيده
جميله كتبها
الرئيس صدام رحمه الله
بحق اهل قطر حقيقه سمو الامير الوالد
ودوله قطر واهل قطر جديرون بهذا الكلام
الطيب ما هي المواقف التي تذكرها عن
الامير الوالد يعني هيك خلف الكواليس اول
مره التقيت سمو الامير الوالد في مؤتمر
وزراء خارجيه الدول الاسلاميه
الذين عقدت في وقت
يعني قصير بعد تسلم لوزاره الخارجيه كان
سمو الامير الوالد عامل دعوه غدا للوزراء
فجئنا نسلم عليه
انا سلمت عليه سلام رسمي يعني تركتم مسافه
تقريبا متر ونصف بيني وبينهم فسحبني اليه
وعانقني
وهمس في اذني اعجابا باللهجه الذي كنت
اثير فيه واتمنياتي تمنياتي بالتوفيق في
سير على هذا النهج الذي يخدم العراق وهذا
حكيم وكانت تلك لفته انسانيه رائعه يعني
من قائد الدوله
لا لم يسبق لي ان تكون عندي علاقه مع
نهائيا هذه اول مره اول لقاء
احنا اتجولنا هوايه في الدوحه الجميله
الان ادعوك نروح عرفك على الاولاد
والاحفاد في بيتنا اتشرف بس عندي شرط واحد
شاي عراقي
وفقد شاي عراقي والنووي ايضا كليجه عراقيه
[موسيقى]
فصلت المسافات صبري عن فراته ونخيله ودار
اهله الذي صار اطلالا وذكرى يحن اليها كل
حين
وبينما يقضي حياته في الغربه كان التفاف
العائله حول الشمعه المضيئه
[موسيقى]
ومؤسسات اهليه هذا على
صعيد المهني فيما يتعلق فيك ماذا عن
العائله ماذا عن زوجتك ماذا عن اولادك
حدثنا عنهم كنت انا اشتغل مساء وصباحا
فكانت ام محمد خير معين لي في اداره شؤون
البيت
ورعايه الاولاد وممارسه تعليمهم متابعه
تعليمهم هي اصلا مدرسه
وفي لندن في
عانتني في اداره المركز الثقافي العراقي
كانت هي تدير كل المسائل الاداريه في في
المركز وفي الدائره على جوانب من عملك
جوانب اللي كان لها صله فيها يعني كانت
تعمل معي في المركز الثقافي وفي الدائره
الصحفيه فطبعا تطلع لكن انا بشكل عام لا
اشرك الاسره في قضايا العمل مشاكل العمل
تنتهي عند ما اخرج انا من مركز العمل اذهب
الى البيت انصرف في البيت لشؤون العائله
عندما جئنا الى هنا انا عندي اربعه اولاد
ندى وهدى
ومحمد واحمد عندي من الاحفاد ثلاثه نور
ونادين وليش الان محمد عنده ناجي
بالصف الثاني متوسط
واحمد عند ناجي الصف الرابع ابتدائي وحسين
والانسه المصون اميره العائله موج عمرها
سنه او اربعه اشهر الذي يتجولا في كافه
انحاء العالم داني كيف
يحاور ابنائه واحفاده كيف اتصف علاقتك
فيهم انا تزوجت في سن مبكره كان عمري 22
سنه فاولادي كبرى في وقت انا ما ازال في
مرحله الشباب ولذلك اصبحوا اصدقاء صار
معهم شوي صار في المبادئ في المسائل
الاساسيه الجوهريه صار طبعا هذا شيء طبيعي
ولكن فيما عدا هذا انا اتعامل معهم اصدقاء
كيف ممكن تخبرهم عن وطنهم وهم بعاد يعني
الطفل وهذا الجيل الجديد اللي ما زار
العراق ولا عرف العراق الا بالصور نحن هنا
بصلتنا المباشره اليوميه دائما مع اهلنا
في العراق
نشرك احفادنا في هذه في هذه الصلاه
فيعرفون انهم
المنتمين للعراق
نشوفهم احنا صور عن العراق
ويسالون عن بغداد يسالون عن الرئيس الراحل
الله يرحمه يعني اسئلتهم هذا الجيل واعيه
والوسائل اللي تخليه يعي الامور متوفره
امام اكثر من جيلنا احنا يعني اقدر اتكلم
معاه عن اي شيء عن العراق عن قطر الاجواء
ما يلعب كوره بس يلعب هوايه البارحه شفتها
يلعب والسباحه
سباحه سباحه
السابقه كل يوم انا او جدي
ماذا تقول للعراق اليوم وحال العراقيين في
الداخل وفي الشتات الوضع الصعب في العراق
معروف للجميع وهو من نتائج الطبيعيه
لهذا الاحتلال المدمر الذي جرى العراق في
عام 2003 ولكن
كلنا امل بالله
وثقه بشعبنا في العراق ان يستطيع ان
يتجاوز هذه المحن وهذه المصائب
ويستعيد عافيته ويستعيد الامن والاستقرار
ويستعيد دوره العراق سيد ودائما كان سيد
في ارضه وسيد على موارده
وشعبه دائما كان متالق
وله دور كبير في في صنع الحضاره الانسانيه
وصنع الحضاره العربيه والاسلاميه
احيانا تمضبين الحياه الى مسارات لم نخطط
لها لكننا نحتاج لاختيار الزاويه المضيئه
والسير نحوها
طريقي مع ناجي الحديث انتهى لكنني ساكمل
الطريق مترقبه لقاء شخص اخر مع جانب اخر
جديد
[موسيقى]